hey bandit
i'm my cookie cookie take my cookie
cookie cookie
it works
i feel very blessed
i have hemorrhoids
becky's gonna have a lot of hair kids
just remember
suicide is never the answer
all right
you know how long i've been waiting for
one of you old men to kiss me he's a
good kid
i gotta say out of the four you i think
vito's the best kisser
we just wanted to ask about the internet
gentlemen
are you eating packing peanuts one night
when i was
philandering crystal caught me kissing
jimmy lynn's
heavy breasts why i'm a human
i'm a human male be as moist no
as juicy as no as wet as you can well
just say
it'll be good man it'll be good man
look how happy he is now
[Music]
[Music]
glass
[Applause]
don't be suspicious don't be suspicious
i'm talking to you donna i'm talking to
you jerry
i'm talking to you mark i'm talking to
you just bounce bounce bounce back so
now all the ladies say and bounce bounce
bounce bounce bounce
dancers
[Music]
little kid lover stanley barack is
president
you are black sadly this is jim
the machine stop yelling at me
i don't care what jim says that is not
the real ben franklin
i am 99 sure where are the turtles
where are the turtles come on guys get
out of here where are the turtles
can someone please throw me a fifth ball
if you dare incoming
do you really expect us to believe
you're somebody else do you really
expect me to not push you up against the
wall beyond are you doing this i don't
know
i am not going to finish
i can't beat rabies nobody can beat
rabies babies have been around for a
thousand years michael watch the road
hey you're making me sprint oh my god
kill you man
michael that is terrible i think i cut
my penis on the lid
this is going to be the happiest day of
my life
no god no
god please no no no
no come kevin
stay kevin come kevin
stay kevin come say stay
come on cookie kevin cookie
there is no cookie kevin is there a
cookie
mm-hmm what come on
derek
again yeah charles wants to say hi
do you have any milk
now you're a try
big smiles bigger bigger great now we
just have to stay like this for the next
two hours
can you feel it working i don't have any
enamel on my teeth so the cold air is
excruciating maybe if you brushed your
teeth once in a while this wouldn't be a
problem
i do brush my teeth they're decaying
from acid reflux
you're embarrassing yourself you're like
you're not australian gina get
stuffed you drongo guys seriously too
much exposure to air and they will turn
to dust
okay okay imagine a letter
had unprotected sex with a phone look
you guys if the sergeant wants to chop
off his penis that is his choice
guess who nypd hands up
my dreams are coming true you and me get
my lady off together
oh put it there pal
yes queen
we are getting aggravated you look like
milli vanilli ooh i call vanilla
i want a vanilla but you got it he's the
best one you know it's true
looks like you and i are in a good
old-fashioned suck-off we got white
shard we got jar and poppers
and for all you freaking vegans out
there
we got shark shots yeah
[Music]
we need to talk
just kidding i don't fall
i'm sorry
oh
my face my face is fine
we are not going to ruin this night
oh
[Music]
is your decapitated head on a stick in
front of your weeping mother
go go go
punk book jockey
taliban robes
pancho rectangle
america megaphone
monday butthole
flowers schedule vows bride
groom food love happy
church event wedding and craig to the
basement
news flash we're screwed
while i'm gone you're in charge
also i keep a sizable supply of ground
chuck in my desk
remove it or it will begin to smell
godspeed
[Music]
keep your eyes on the creek
you